I was a weird kid and I wanted the
popular girls to accept me into their
group and I thought having a screen name
like this would trick them into thinking
I was one of them what else 13 Johnson
was my favorite wrestler any cautis fans
a chain gang and made me 13 at the time
had to add a 69 at the end I mean what
else can you expect from a person who
wears her name in hoop earrings Sun
Cuban and proud fresh out of the
quinceanera stage so I chose Harry J 69
when I was 18 and in college because I'm
Harry extremely Harry I'm Jewish and I
like to 69 I chose this screen name
because I wanted to live in California I
thought that's where all the pretty and
popular people lived there wasn't much
miss color this is genius
all right like when you're scanning your
friends list you wonder who's on and
then when you see that I'm on you're
like hey Ryan is on I had to be X
because I forgot my password I'm pretty
proud of it actually hold up what that
never occurred to me oh my god you threw
me off man I'm like you really did I
chose this name when I was about 13
years old statehood it's because I
thought I would stay ghetto brat is
because I was spoiled and zero one three
well because I'm an Aquarius
chubby star cuz I was a little thick
growing up and clearly I'm a star I
don't know why I chose 27 actually
that's my age right now maybe this is
all like full circle I wasn't very good
at girls so I thought that maybe being
quirky and slapstick would help it
didn't I was shocked when this was not
taken it's not ironic enough to be funny
it's it's more painful I don't know why
I thought this was cool or okay or
acceptable in any way
I thought farts were hilarious as a
junior high student and sad part is I
was
in 83 not 87 heart/liver 83 was taken so
I'm not alone in my loving it's all was
13 I was trying to get girls online and
I thought I was a cyber Casanova I like
to not live with regrets I was trying to
get chicks on AOL I really liked soccer
and I liked the word dude I thought dude
that sounded weird I didn't want to have
a number so my dad suggested I I cuz it
means ii so my aim name is technically
soccer due to the second i made up this
word and i don't know what it means at
all i have no idea what i was going for
with this my aim name it was a black
Barbie koku 367 because it combined my
four favorite things being black playing
with Barbies Goku from Dragon Ball Z and
367 because that was my crushes Locker
number I'm not ashamed you know what I'm
a little embarrassed I said I thought it
was the king of aim but uh